so we're told the entire figure is one
hole so that is this entire square right
over there and then they ask us which
multiplication equation best represents
the figure and so we're supposed to
choose one of these four right over here
so pause this video try it on your own
before we work through it together
all right now let's work through it
together so this whole square is a hole
and now let's first think about what's
going on with this three tenths so
they've labeled the three tenths as
three of these vertical bars right over
here we could view the three tenths as
these three vertical bars
and then they also have this seven
tenths which are
seven of these horizontal bars and
notice each of those bars are a tenth of
the whole
so we have seven of these horizontal
bars if that doesn't look like seven
bars let me just draw it this way so
that's one two three
four
five six six and seven and of course we
see something similar with these
vertical bars that's one
two and three
now what's going on here is we're
looking at where these bars overlap and
one way to think about that is the
overlap is going to be three tenths
times seven tenths you could view this
overlap let me just in another color
right over here this overlap right over
here you could view that as seven tenths
of the three tenths or three tenths of
the seven tenths or seven tenths times
three tenths so we immediately know it's
going to be either this choice that has
three tenths times seven tenths or this
choice that has three times three tenths
times seven tenths but let's see what
this should be well when we look at that
overlap we get 21 of these squares
because we have 7 in this direction 3 in
this direction I could count them but we
have 21 squares here and each of those
squares are what fraction of the whole
well each of those squares are now one
hundredth of the whole because this is
now a 10 by 10 grid each of those is one
hundredth so in the overlap we have 21
of these squares that's 21 hundredths so
21 hundredths is
0.21 that's the same thing as 21 over
100 which is this choice right there and
we're done